[ __ ] i remember mike yes well go say you
ain't laughing at me he'd be in five
minutes and walk off stage back in his
early days like man yeah ain't laughing
at me i'm here going home as i brought
him down and everything yeah i've been
knowing these guys a long time sounds
like you at bronner's brothers oh yeah 2
a.m
then you dip early on that one no
actually i did i
finished my act oh i thought you left
your set early because you're like
she told you to be clean and then you're
like eff it yeah well
oh my god that was that was uh
that was i didn't leave though honestly
i did i went out doing 25 30 minutes oh
okay i stayed up there but everybody
else was leaving
you know so i was like what did i do
i mean you know i thought
it was seemed like a great crowd ryan
manning went up they all these guys went
up they were doing blue
i mean pat brown funny female comedian
she
she she she had brought me up damon will
damon williams who went up he killed
what he was doing he was doing dirty
jokes but she going you be clean and i
was like
pat said this no no no no
yeah yeah whoever miss brown or whatever
yeah yeah
who i won't have to ever worry about she
would love to have me do our show now
but yesterday's price is not today's
price
is not today's price sweetheart thank
you sweetie you have a nice day okay
but
she
came to me and said that so i'm doing
clean and i had no problem with that i
do church but my whole energy was it was
like man they do dirty i come and do
clean it's not going to blend because
but i thought that when i wasn't doing
dirty the crowd was uh he cleaned i got
to go but but that's where i met my wife
i love you to shine i met my wife there
at the valley that that was during
valentine's day weekend
and i
and i got mad i was just like done
i was just like man i was hurt man
because i said it was a big show they
bragged on how big it is and i'm just
thinking to myself man
what what did i do man people just
walking out on me you know i said they
didn't like me but when i walked in the
back
that's when damien williams came and got
me saying hey lavell it's about two
three hundred people out here
on pitches
so i'm like i know everybody was gone
but it wasn't that they was walking out
they said the buses was leaving my wife
that's the wife that i met my woman
my wife now she was she was there she
was one of the women taking a picture
with me and i called her blue jeans man
it was a kind of a chance meeting
because she missed my where are you
staying at and i wouldn't tell her
exactly where i was standing i told her
the hotel but i didn't tell her what
room but she got fake like she was my
wife and was able to leave a message on
my bro so that's how ironic talk about
speaking some of this this yeah it might
be the pivotal interview to turn it over
let's go you know so so when she said
that
when i called her back and we talked we
talked for hours
and
lo and behold he had some moments in
himself but it was it was meant to be
and we've been married ever since going
on 15 years but she the one said no they
was leaving because the buses was
leaving
and they had to get on if they you know
some of them weren't staying downtown
they were staying out and the crazy
thing about it my hotel was just we had
went me and tony roberts and damian
williams had
walked from my hotel in the days at the
uh holiday inn at the time over to the
days ends when he had a diner downstairs
to eat he had a denny's down there i
think he did that had a dinner down
there he went down there to eat me and
him and i guess they had met some
females so and i'm just sitting there
man i just i wanted something to eat she
was in that hotel but strange enough we
never we never saw each other that night
but the next the next day we talked on
the phone taught on the phone and then
we wind up
everything started meshing together it
was interesting you know i honestly i i
knew a girl down there but she didn't
show up and so i i was mad about that
i didn't know her at the time so but if
we wind up i guess that was the reason
why she didn't show up because i was
meeting the one for me
so
that's beautiful yeah that's beautiful
yeah this clip is one of hundreds we
have here at hop breath so click right
here to subscribe and check them out and
then jump to this video i picked just
for you
sorry about the eyebrows